هذا لا يبدو كما لو أنه
يتحسن بأي حال من
الأحوال، أعني أن الأمور أصبحت
سيئة للغاية في هذه المرحلة وكانت هناك
آمال كبيرة في أن عملية
Prosperity Guardian كما يطلق عليها
وهي جهد أمني متعدد الجنسيات
بقيادة البحرية الأمريكية ستنجح  بذلت الكثير لنقل
بعض المخاوف وكانت MK في الواقع
إحدى شركات الشحن التي
قررت الاستمرار في هذا الطريق بعد أن أوقفته مؤقتًا
في نهاية العام الماضي
الآن منذ يوم الأحد اضطرت إلى إصدار
توقف آخر لمدة 48 48 ساعة وذلك
لأنه  لقد قلت أنها تعرضت للهجوم
وكان من المثير للاهتمام أن يكون هناك
هجوم جوي من نوع ما بجسم غير معروف
ثم أطلقت أربعة قوارب من طراز هوتي النار
عليها بشكل مباشر،
ثم أغرقت مروحية تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية ثلاثة منها
أه مما أسفر عن مقتل جميع من كانوا على متنها،
لذلك  يبدو أن هناك تصعيدًا آخر
لا يزال يتعين رؤيته في هذه المرحلة حيث
سيقرر M أنهم سيعيدون
مسار العبور هذا مرة أخرى، لذلك نحن ننتظر
بيانًا منهم، وهذا حقًا أمر
مقلق حقًا، أعني أننا
نعرف الصراع في غزة  بالطبع أم
كانت في المقدمة والوسط فيما يتعلق
بالنوع الأخير من 100 يوم
والكثير من الحديث حول ما إذا كان هذا الصراع
يمكن أن ينزلق خارج أه المنطقة التي
يوجد فيها وهذه منطقة الخليج
أه واحدة من تلك المناطق بالنظر إلى أن الحوثي
لقد تدخلت هنا، ومن
الواضح أن هذا يمكن أن يكون له تأثير على
أسعار النفط، فنحن نشهد ارتفاعًا كبيرًا في السعر،
ما الذي يمكن أن نتوقعه، هل تعتقد في هذه
المرحلة جيدًا أن هناك عددًا من
المخاوف هنا بشأن النفط، خاصة أولاً
وقبل كل شيء، هذا هو  طريق مهم حقًا
لناقلات النفط بالطبع
وبعضهم مثل شركة بريتيش بتروليوم يسلكون بالفعل
طريقًا طويلًا جدًا، وهناك أيضًا
خطر كبير للتصعيد في هذه المرحلة،
كان لديك سفينة حربية تابعة للبحرية الإيرانية أه تدخل
البحر الأحمر في آخر 24 ساعة  ساعات
ردًا على ذلك، أتخيل ما
نراه فيما يتعلق بالجهود المتعددة الجنسيات
لمحاولة تأمين
طريق العبور، لذا فأنت ترى هذا بالفعل
وأعتقد أن السؤال الكبير في المستقبل
سيكون ما إذا كانت الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤها أم لا
يقررون الاستمرار في التصرف
دفاعًا عن النفس أو ما إذا كانوا سيصلون إلى
نقطة ما، سواء كانوا على استعداد لمهاجمة
مواقع الحوثيين في اليمن، الأمر الذي سيكون بمثابة
تصعيد كبير، لا، هذا
شيء في المنطقة التي
نتواجد فيها عادةً  الخليج في
أبو ظبي يراقب الوضع بشكل حقيقي في
الوقت الحالي أم أن أسعار النفط كانت في الواقع
مستقرة نسبيًا خلال
الصراع في الشرق الأوسط أم أن هذا
ليس شيئًا أراد الناس بالضرورة
رؤيته في بداية
العام وليس من الواضح سبب ذلك
تحركت سفينة إيرانية إلى البحر الأحمر ولكن
التخمين كما
أشرت بحق هو رد على هذا أه
التحالف الراغب في دعم
أمريكا